drinking waters being shut off in all of
Detroit's public schools after testing
revealed harmful levels of copper and
lead in multiple buildings water quality
issues have now been detected in 34
schools nearly a third of the district
DeMarco Morgan is in Detroit where one
mother is demanding answers about how
this happened and why parents weren't
notified sooner
DeMarco good morning good morning to you
new tests revealed this week revealed
that the Marcus Garvey Academy right
here behind me is one of those 34
schools where the water is not safe to
drink and now the district is scrambling
to reach out to parents to robo calls
and letters because the first day of
school starts next Tuesday I haven't
been notified and I lived literally a
block away from the school when top of
the Harmons daughter Paris arrives at
her first day of kindergarten at the
Marcus Garvey Academy next week none of
the water fountains or faucets will be
working because the water is
contaminated I'm worried because it
starts things that I trained her to do
like wash their hands what about
drinking that water yes how do they
prepare lunch how to do lunch a swatch
they have it's unclear how long children
have been drinking the tainted water the
culprit appears to be aging metal pipes
inside the school itself awesome alone
the grass they cook why you didn't make
sure to water stay clean frustration yes
Nikolay VT ordered tests on every
drinking fountain and faucet in the
district something not required by any
federal state or local law high levels
of lead and or copper were found at 16
schools 18 more tested positive for
contaminants and 2016 as a precaution vt
shut off the water at every school
affecting more than 47,000 students
bottled water is being provided and
there has been a lack of investment
within each right public school systems
and so this has build up over time
Councilwoman Mary chef Hill says many of
the schools with tainted water are in
her district
she thinks fixing all of Detroit's
school infrastructure problems could
cost half a billion dollars they're in
deplorable conditions I mean we've had
reports of mold and mice and roaches
running through our schools you have to
make sure that we are allocating
appropriate funding to address these
needs and and finally really put our
children first the utilities company
that supplies the city's drinking water
says the tainted water problems do not
go beyond Detroit's Public Schools they
say the water is safe because it's
tested hourly and it's safe to drink and
that residents should not worry about
widespread contamination similar to what
happened in Flint Michigan Nora
DeMarco thanks Adriana you were there in
Flint you covered this story I mean how
did what do you see about the
similarities well in Flint that was
man-made there was a switch that was
made to save money and that led to the
lead contamination there and though the
government says there the contamination
is God residents don't feel that way and
everyone's still buying bottled water in
Flint so that continues Detroit it looks
like that has to do with aging pipes so
as the lady said in the interview they
were cutting the grass who was watching
the pipes yeah well when they say the
government says the water is safe to
drink
people must just think they roll their
eyes on Thursday and they say okay sure
I just it's such a huge problem as we
have documented on the show you've done
such great reporting we cannot have our
children exposed this leads to lifelong
developmental problems and a big issue